[Mark] Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier,
[Circus Baby] The only
[Mark] and welcome back to Five Nights at Freddy's: Sister Location.
[Circus Baby] thing that matters... is knowing.
[Mark] Now I did that thing in the last episode where I start a bunch of thoughts,
[Circus Baby] How. To. Pretend.
[Mark] and uh, I don't finish them, because *Alarm goes off* I'm in a blind panic,
because I'm in a blind PANIC.
and I have no idea what I'm doing
and everything is going all *banging* curfuckled around me *banging*
and *laugh* *MORE banging*
I'm just trying to survive, so I didn't think things through.
So in this thing which is a spring lock type animatronic,
[Circus Baby] I'll open the faceplates for you.
which is very bizarre
[Mark] Number 1, because why is that here,  [Circus Baby] That way they can find you on the cameras
[Mark] and not in Freddy Faz bears Pizzeria [Circus Baby] And all you have to do
[Mark] why is that a left over thing? But also,
[Circus Baby] is wait.
these things that were crawling up the side, I totally forgot that I can wiggle-
[Circus Baby] I'd recommend that you keep the springlocks wound up.
[Circus Baby] Your breathing
[Mark] Oh boy.
[Circus Baby] and heartbeat
[Circus Baby] are causing them to come loose.
[Mark] Yeah I know, I know
and also my wiggling.
[Circus Baby] You don't want them to get too loose
I know, and my wiggling
[Circus Baby] Trust me.
I gotcha.
So, I did not know that I could wiggle
so I think it's going to be a balance of wiggling
versus knocking these things off
and I don't know where they are;
there's one crawling up already- it is, so hyah!
Wiggle!
HAHAAA!
that was correct!
That was absolutely correct.
So I just need to strike a balance
and actually USE my BRAIN and try to
naww
get off of here
So, I'm going to get this
Oh my god, then wiggl-
Oh geeEEEEEZ
That is not good
That's not good, I can hear you clambering up my leg, you biiiiitch.
Ok, so I'm just going to hold this down and clankdy dank my way...
Where is he? I thought I heard him.
I must have shook him off all the way down
So... wh-what I want to know is
what room am I in, where am I in this world, like they were looking for me?
Which meant that there are some people employers somewhere around here and I don't know...
who they might be or what they're doing
but whoever it is, is the person that's looking on the security camera
so some other human person- OH geez
Oh geez, how close was that to killing me?
Oh geez, probably extremely and I don't wanna know exactly how close but probably a lot close.
Oh geez, this is a constant battle
HAY
OH
WIGGLING
I'M WIGGLING *Scrrreeeaaammm*
I'M-
I WAS WIGGLING!
*Minirina shrieking*
I WAS WIG-WAGGLING!!
I WAS WABBLE-JABBLING!!!
*Angry sigh*
Okay.
That didn't work.
I didn't pay attention to them crawling up my grundle.
Alright, lets try this again, but I know the general strategy
so we're going to get pretty far now.
Hopefully.
Oh, man.
You know what this is reminiscent of?
It's reminiscent of the music box
you know, the first *laughs*
from, uh, Five Nights at Freddy's 2
constantly keeping the music box wound
and then having to
flip back and forth
between the two of them-
I don't even hear them crawling up
I'm just going to have to
guess that their crawling up like every 20 seconds or so
and then try to do something about that
but I still don't know
if I'm going to have enough time
to be able to do all this shit
so I gotta be really precise about where my mouse goes
from
flit to flit and-
Aw man, that knocks everything
so I can't do that unnecessarily, which I just did
to try to shake something off
that I don't even know if there was something there
So I'm fuuuucked
I gotta like go back and forth between it
because I just can't do
I can't just do
on one side
I gotta be quick
Ohh jeez
No- I see you there
whoa whoa, hey whoa wait I fuck I WHAT
I-I'm wigg-
*Minirina shrieking*
I was
wIGGLING??
waggling
Oh god, not again.
I don't know if imma able ta do dis
*virtual disintegrating sounds*
ooohhh
okay...
alrightey then...
I still don't know what that's about
and I don't know why I'm doing that
but I'm doing it
and I'm doing it for you
cuz I love you
*scared mumblings*
So I still don't know how to figure out like...
how do you- how do you bash them off when they're coming up the front?
There was two coming up the front
wait, there...there he is
he- he came
So...
What the fuck?
What was that?
*softly* What...
So I just need to not mind them crawling
inside my suit here and I'm gonna die
these are- these are this bad this bad this very bad
what you would call, real real real real real
real rill 'rl bad
I'm- I'm fooooobbernucked
I'm fooobbernucked
I'm fobbernucked
So you just you just don't
look at 'em is-is the thing?
Geez
How are you not supposed to look at...
crawling inside your suit?
Oh god I'm dead, I'm-I'm so dead there's-there's literally no way.
There's literally no way.
How in the hell?
They're all- AHHH!
*Minirina shrieking*
Fuck!
They're all looking at me like, what?
What do I do? Holy shit I can't-
That's insane. That's insanity.
How the hell are you supposed to do that?
Oh man...
Holy crap... I don't- I don't know if I understand this.
I don't know if I know if I understand anything is going on- Ooo, hey, hey.
Don't mind me! Not looking at you, why would I be looking at you?
Why would anybody looking at your ugly face?
Oh boy, there's another one.
Okay, I'm not going to be able to get the ones of the low-
Oh Jesus, oh geez, oh geez oh
*Mildly distressed Mark*
*Minirina shrieking*
So...
Hooow?
Hooooow??
How in the heck?
How in the hecky heck?
How in the frick damn heck?
how in the hecky hecky
Maybe it's not...
Maybe it's not that you can't look at them,
maybe it's you can't wiggle when there's one crawling in
I think that might be it?
but holy hecky heck
This is getting obscenely difficult.
like... wowwy zowwy, hoopy powey
See that one-
he crawls right in and that's fine, I guess?
Don't mind that...
It's a little weird, but I mean I guess I don't mind it.
I guess it's suppose to be like a sense of unease considering they're...
literally going into my suit here.
That's my private area but...
So Imma try to wait-
I am not going to get them like right off the bat
because, #1, I got people crawling up the sides anyway
So boop boop boop, there it goes
Ok this is a bit more manageable.
I think- I think I can I think I can deal with this
Ok, so not when they're coming up, not they're coming up
they're coming up, oh geez... more more MORE
I got my eye on you... FUCK. Ok, it's ok... apparently...
Fucking... there's so many of them!
So goddamn many of them...
is now we got a lot on *leugh* on alert, on alert...
fuucking fuucking fuucking fuucking fuucking fuck
fuck, we are in trouble- we're fucked how in the
FFFFUCK are you supposed to be able to
do this? How in the fal-lying fuck?
Like honestly though there's no way
It's like-
*Minirina shrieking*
no way how in the fuck would you be able to do that??
How would anybody???
Am I missing a key component here,
'cause holy shit!
Okay i think there might be a-
a significant benefit to getting them all
the way wound as opposed to only
partially and then moving on because it
seems to stay... wound for a little bit
longer when you get them all the way up.
Which is good... all things considered
So I think this is the only way that
you're going to be able to survive is
is just if you do ALL of these ALL the way
up cause otherwise, you're just a whole
lot of boned... and that's no good.
Yep, losing battle now is this there's no
way
goddamn it
just no way
i just don't
see how it's feasible.
*Minirina shrieking*
Yeah.
*groans*
There really is something like not evident here cause
there doesn't seem- like it-it's- it's an
exercise of time, right, like how long Ima
ima actually do a timer just because
like a stopwatch and i'm at a time from
the first moment that I can do this [Circus Baby] I'll open the face plates for you
[Circus Baby] That way they can find you on the cameras
[Mark] I'm going to...
[Circus Baby] Now all you have to do is wait.
[Circus Baby] I recommend that you keep the
[Mark] Bam, okay. So I'm timing this [Circus Baby] spring locks--
this to try to get a general sense of
like, if I can last a long time and then
fail, I'll know exactly like, what I need
to do. But... you know, it just doesn't seem
like
it's
something, and I'm going back and
forth because there seems to be like,
uh, something else that's causing me to die
if I stay looking only at one side for a while?
And I don't know what that's about
but you know, I'm just trying to...
trying to get by and we're just starting to
lose it, this is where everything starts
to go past
the point where you can really keep it
up with, so you can't exactly get
everything to full, you know, and we just
crossed two minutes right there
So if I had to guess, it's probably like
any other Five Nights at Freddy's night
and you have to last six minutes, but I
don't see how anybody...
with the amount of wiggling that you have to do, I don't see
how anybody could last six full minutes here?
Because it just seems like an
impossibility, unless we're going to
three, because it seems like I might fail
like, somewhere close to three minutes?
But with the amount of wiggling that you
have to do, especially like towards the
end here, like, it's just a little too
much for like, someone to be able to
handle but I'm gonna try to get to three
full minutes here, but this wiggle's gonna kill me.
Yep, that wiggle killed me.
*Minirina shrieking*
Unless we're going
to three minutes, which we might be, but
even so? With the amount of wiggling it's
just like, a little too much wiggling!
Unless you have to wait for like, that-
them to get to the very tip-top because
they get up pretty dang high before you
die from them? So maybe you have to wait
until like, you get a double so you only
wiggle like one time and that will be
just enough to save you in the end, but...
We-I'll, I'll try that method and then
see how high we can get.
[Circus Baby] I'll open the face plates for you
[Mark] Because that seems like the only possible solution there. [Circus Baby] That way they can find you on--
So that guy's climbing up...
You can obviously see that. So I'm gonna let him
get as high as possible...
And then... bingo bango bongo. Got two of them.
Okay, so that's good, got two at once
2 for combo, I'll always take that.
Okay, one's over there
Two's over there
Okay, so there's two of them. There's definitely two of them.
Kay... we're gonna get this one off
Boink boink boink!
So that one takes four.
I think I distinctly remember that
happening too, like the last time I was
over there it took four as well?
I'm just not a hundred percent sure...
about anything at this point, but I'm just gonna try to
let him get as high as possible. We just
crossed to a minute thirty, so we're doing ok,
but I know it's about now is when it
starts to fall apart.
Because there's really no recovering after a certain point
Two-twenty right now
Oh god, how far was that along?
See, I le-
I let him get super high, but that guy
came along and fucked up my day
God damn it. Okay, this is... stressful.
Not dead yet
But we're dang close
fuck
fuuuck
fuck fuck fuck fuCK FUCK
OOH YES
YES
IT WAS THREE MINUTES
FUCK YEAH!
YES!
YEES!
It was only three- I knew it had to be like three minutes!
Oh god yes!
What, do I just go home after this?
What, do I just shovel popcorn in my gullet?
Do I just... Oh, whatever!
[TV announcer] As the moon rises,
[Mark] Oh, a good day at work! *eating noises*
[TV announcer] so also rises the tension
*more eating noises*
[TV announcer] between sworn lovers!
[Vlad] Clara, it's not my baby!
[Mark] Oh my god.
[Clara] Vlad, you suck.
[Vlad]  Wait, was that a vampire joke?
[Mark] Ohhh my god.
*Agressive sigh*
[Vlad] That was so lame, Clara!
*Mark sighs*
mkay
[Vlad] Like I haven't heard that a million times!
[Clara] Okay, well, how's this?
[Mark] Three minutes is what it was.
[Clara] I'm taking the car!
[Vlad] The joke's on you, it's a rental!
[Mark] Hahah!
[Clara] Well, the joke's on you! I set the thermostat to 90 before I left!
[Vlad] Good, I like it warm!
[Clara] Good! Because I also set the house on fire!
[TV announcer] How will it all end?
[Mark] Oh! *laughs*
[TV announcer] The passion! The tension! The intrigue!
Tune in tomorrow for the exciting conclusion!
[Mark] Uh-huh.
Ok then. So, we did that! Holy shit!
That was like, really difficult for being in
the main game, night four there, that's
really tough! The secret to-
[Little Girl Voice] Daddy isn't watching.
[Mark] What'd you say?
I gotta stop talking after that-
[Hand Unit] Welcome back to your last day on the job.
[Mark] Oh yay! Last day.
[Hand Unit] That is, the last day of your first week.
Some of the most valued qualities that we like to see in new
employees are determination, fearlessness
and a genuine disregard for instinctive self-preservation.
[Mark] yeeah
[Hand Unit] You've earned your one-week bonus
which will be given to you in the form
of a delightful gift basket, the cost of
which will be taken out of your next
paycheck. We've gift baskets containing fruit, nuts,
*Mark laughing*
flowers and of course, the ever-popular cash basket.
Using the keypad below,
please enter the first few letters of
the gift basket you would like to receive.
[Mark]  Well, it doesn't matter if I get
the cash basket, you're only gonna take
it out of my goddamn paycheck!
[Hand Unit] It seems you had some
trouble with the keypad. I see what you were
trying to type and I will auto-correct
it for you.
Thank you for selecting... EXOTIC BUTTERS. ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
*Mark laughs*
[Mark] Yeah! Actually, that sounds okay!
Me do love some butter! I love good whole-
[Hand Unit] Just be aware there are still two technicians
on-site today. Try to avoid interfering
with their work if possible.
Also, feel free to ask them why they are
still there and encourage them to go home.
[Mark] What?
Wait, there's two other technicians here?
Are they alive? That's my first question
If I only get 20 questions here, my first
one is going to be: Are they alive, or am
I gonna find their dead ass in the
middle of the goddamn vent?
*sighs*
I have no idea if I am, but either way, I think I'm
out of time for this episode. I've really
been plowing through this one.
It took a long, long, long time to get
through that over-repetitive
relentlessness to it, which is surprising
considering it's only night four, but now
we're going in to night five, so-
Eh, we can find out a little bit more. I'm going to get
to the other room first and then we're
gonna end it here, because I wanted-
I realized I've been doing the same thing
for a long time, I want to see, like just
a little bit of what else is here if
there is some of-
[Funtime Foxy] Motion trigger - Entry-way vent.
[Mark] If there is something else story-wise, I want to get
a bit more story before I leave you guys.
Because I'd hate to just be like: Ah, me try, me try!
[Hand Unit] Let's check on Ballora and make sure she's on her stage.
[Mark] Yeah, okay, how about that?
Auuh...
[Hand Unit] Great. Now let's check on Funtime Foxy.
[Mark] *groans*
[Hand Unit] Great! It looks like everything is as it should be in Funtime Auditorium.
[Mark] *Groans loudly*
[Hand Unit] Your task today will
involve more maintenance work.
Circus Baby had a rough day and is in need of
repair. You will be required to reach the
Parts and Service Room by once again
sneaking through Funtime Auditorium.
[Mark] *Scared noise*
[Hand Unit] As always please, proceed with caution.
[Mark] I don't wanna!
Oh god! Okay, so...
that's the next thing that I need to do and I'm not
gonna do that! So I know where the two
other technicians are!
*Groans* They're...
Eugh... So either way, that is all that
I'm gonna do for this one, I'm gonna
finish this up or, quote-unquote, "finish it up"
because we all know that night 5 is
never the last night, in the next video
So thank you everybody so much for
watching. Let me know how I did down in the
comments below and as always I will see you
in the next video.
BYE-BYE!!
(Wave bye to Markimoo!)
(Mark's amazing outro music)
[Subtitles edited by ImpactedGolem13]